now the democrats vaccine mandate power
trip has now made it of course to our
southern border but not for the untold
millions of migrants illegally entering
the country as i just said instead the
bite administration is now poised to
punish customs and border patrol agents
can't make this up republican ohio
congressman jim jordan joins me now
exclusively
congressman
you were recently approached by a
whistleblower
on this subject what did you learn
whistleblower told us that the border
patrol was given official notice that
border patrol agents don't get the
vaccine by november of this year so six
weeks from now if they don't get the
vaccine they're going to be fired a fire
so meanwhile today we had a briefing
from secretary mayorkas and we asked him
about what's happening with these this
flood of migrants coming across the
border our southern border and he said
relative to the vaccine he said we ask
them if they want it it's their choice
so think about that the people who have
been busting their tails enforcing our
law doing their job on the border
they're going to get fired if they don't
take the vaccine meanwhile for people
who break the law and come in here no
big deal no your choice it's up to you
that is how ridiculous the biden
administration has become these people
who just a year ago like doctors and
nurses and police officers were heroes
now they're saying we're you're going to
lose your job if you don't take a
vaccine the same vaccine by the way the
kamala harris said she wouldn't take a
year ago this is ridiculous and the
american people know it's ridiculous
yeah so we're going to have we have
nursing shortages
police officers being fired they're
bringing in foreign workers to take the
jobs of americans who
don't don't get the vaccine
again you keep saying waking up saying
is this really the country that we were
born in uh it doesn't seem like it
now i just want to add this congressman
because even before this whistleblower
news
border patrol
we know was already suffering from these
personnel shortages because in a june
report from the national treasury
employees union they said the agency's
own workload staffing models show a
shortage of 1700
cbp officers and 400 other specialists
and 200 non-uniform trade specialists
so
this vaccine mandate is gonna hurt the
hospitals they were supposed to save
it's gonna make the border even less
secure
yep no exactly right they were already
short-handed it's gonna it's gonna make
the problem worse as you say across the
board in in hospitals and in police
police departments and on our southern
border the only conclusion relative to
the border you can reach is this is
intentional this is deliberate the bite
administration we're not going we're
going to stop building the wall we're
going to stop the remaining mexico
policy and we're going to fire agents if
that isn't this goal of a borderless
hemisphere and if that isn't deliberate
i don't know what is so this is again
what is so scary what is so frightening
about this administration this is what
this is what they must want because
there is no other conclusion any
rational person can reach that is what's
frightening i think to me and certainly
to the american people yeah they're
they're trying to bring as many in as
possible before biden's out of office or
before they lose control of congress um
by the way the dhs secretary congressman
did make an admission
about migrants in covet he was speaking
at georgetown yesterday
we are confronted with a
a
a population of people
that um
uh as a general matter
um have a
a rate of illness of approximately 20
percent
and we're firing nurses
and border patrol and police and
teachers
and we're given illegals who break the
law we're giving them the choice whether
they get the facts this this is
it makes it makes absolutely no sense it
is is but this is the same secretary who
a week and a half ago told us the border
is secure i mean that's the thing that
bothers them we're sick of being lied to
by people we're sick of the false
information the misleading information
for for the secretary to say the border
secured makes no sense because it's just
not true no i said he was proud he was
proud proud of how it was going at the
border congressman
thank you for this information tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else